president vladimir zelinski has sharply
criticized the human rights organization
amnesty international after it alleged
ukraine had endangered civilians by
basing its troops in residential areas
zielinski equated the claim to victim
blaming and meanwhile on the ground in
ukraine there are reports of heavy
fighting in the south close to the
russian-held city of hassan and in the
eastern donetsk region ukrainian
civilians have fled their homes forced
to leave by incessant russian shelling
a train station in donetsk evacuating
the old
and the young
all exhausted
westwards
ordinary ukrainians caught up in fierce
fighting and forced to leave their homes
with whatever they can carry
we are from a village near
between the luhansk and donetsk regions
our village has been ruined there's no
gas no water no electricity we were
sitting in the basement for a month the
army brought us here
the government has ordered civilians to
leave combat zones in donetsk
but the danger may not be just from
russian attacks
amnesty international accuses ukraine of
basing troops in populated areas putting
civilians at risk and violating the laws
of war keeve was furious
if someone prepares a report in which
the victim and the aggressor are
allegedly the same in some way
if information about the victim is
analyzed while something the aggressor
does is ignored this cannot be tolerated
i understand that this particular piece
of work because it's critical of the
behavior of uh
of ukrainian forces is not appreciated
by the ukrainian authorities and by many
others but the fact is that you know
international law
applies to
everyone ukrainian soldiers face a
grinding battle to keep the remaining
regions of eastern donbass out of
russian control
and to avoid shelling
the enemy shells us and we can't even
stick our heads out
now there are no small arms fights as
there used to be
today it is an artillery battle
you just jump into the trench and wait
for the strike
away from the front lines the evacuation
of civilians from donetsk continues
the question is whether that will be
enough to keep them safe
let's dig into this with dw
correspondent matthias bolenga in kiev
uh matias i'd like to talk more about
that report from amnesty international
that we just heard about you've read it
what is the human rights organization
accusing ukraine of exactly
well the the i'm this international is
saying that uh uh ukraine is basing
troops near civilian objects near
residential areas that they're using
schools and hospitals to host troops and
that that would put civilians at danger
because these
schools or hospitals would then be
bombed and
and and uh
then also neighboring um
apartment blocks or whatever civilian
object shops etc
might be also hit so they are basically
accusing ukraine of not duly protecting
civilians uh by this these tactics and
they are suggesting that ukraine would
better
keep its troops either in designated
military compounds or they've also
written in woods nearby or similar
places so that they would not be close
to civilians and that any attack on them
would not endanger civilians
now you've been covering the war in
ukraine since russia's invasion based on
your experience how accurate are the
reports findings
so the fact that uh ukrainian troops are
in the cities in the city same cities of
course that where civilians
live that's not a secret um everybody
knows that and i have also seen um
troops being in in public buildings in
buildings that used to be uh used to
civilian purposes before the war um so
this is definitely happening and it's
definitely happening that uh close to
these areas uh
shells go down that people suspect that
they were aimed at these
specific facilities but there are
several flaws in this report first of
all of course
we've asked the same question actually
to military commanders to civilian
administrative personnel politicians in
ukraine and what we heard was how do you
protect the city um the russians are
trying to take these cities and we need
to defend them so how do you defend the
city without being in the city and
that's something of course
amnesty's military advice might not be
very
adequate on you cannot defend the city
by hosting your troops in the forest
nearby and the ukrainian army pretty
much fears open field battles because
they say they don't have the capacity to
meet russians in the open field that
would be a very dangerous tactics for
for the soldiers and lead to many
casualties among the soldiers um so in
order to protect the cities they need to
be in there i've also also said that um
when talking specifically about
buildings like schools or or or whatever
it was at that
specific
time that they always evacuate these
buildings they're not hosting the
soldiers in the same facility where
civilians are
and uh that there is often no
alternative because these are the only
sturdy buildings but the biggest
um flaw of this report is that they
accuse ukraine of not doing enough to
protect the civilians by evacuating them
now that's outrightly false because
ukraine has started a huge evacuation
mission from
the donbass in april they've asked every
civilian to leave the region and they've
also offered transport and evacuation
trains buses etc and these have been
running until the last moment they have
been attacked by the russians if you
remember the attack on kramatosk so um
this is outrightly false and they do not
even mention these efforts um so this is
definitely a a problem of this report
okay matias boeing for us in ukraine
thank you for that update
and for more on this let's bring in
donatello rivera she's a senior crisis
response advisor at amnesty
international welcome ms rover your
organization accuses ukrainian forces of
violating international law can you give
us more details
yes the press release that we
issued is based on the documentation
carried out over a number of months in
different areas of ukraine
where
our researchers have observed
ukrainian forces basing themselves in
schools
residential buildings at time hospitals
in close proximity to where civilians
live
uh which of course um endangers those
civilians who who live
in the in these buildings where the
soldiers uh locate themselves right next
to them
um and and uh
mr international our concern is with the
protection of civilians
and
such conduct is uh in violation of
international law and puts civilians at
risk so that's why we are raising this
issue
the report has been met with with quite
fierce backlash from the ukrainian
president though he is accusing amnesty
a victim blaming what do you make of
that
well that is regrettable because i think
if he takes a look at amnesty's website
he will find
a very significant body of work several
reports many more press releases based
on our field investigations where we
document extensively and in great
details uh war crimes and other serious
violations of international law by
russian forces including use of banned
weapons indiscriminate and deliberate
strikes on civilians extrajudicial
execution torture abductions
so we as amnesty international have been
carrying out field investigations on the
ground in ukraine and documenting in
great details russia's war crimes for
the past six months all this information
is available on the public record on our
website that those reports have
generally
been met
with praise now the team that carried
out the research on these particular
press release that we issued yesterday
it's the same team of people the same
researchers using the same methodology
so it's not really credible to say that
99
of our work is great and proper uh and
good and and one
piece of work
that details uh violations by ukrainian
forces which have also been documented
by others yeah including the u.n human
rights which another to say it wasn't
just
upset by the report sorry to interject
there i want to talk about something
that has kind of caught our attention
the head of your ukraine bureau oksana
pokalchok wrote in a social media post
that she tried to stop the publication
of this report saying the country team
was not involved and that the findings
are based on quote inadmissible and
incomplete material what went wrong
there
um i don't know i think that the only
person who
could explain that would be the person
who made that statement i would simply
point out that amnesty ukraine has not
been involved in carrying out any
investigation or documenting
the
war crimes uh committed by russia since
the beginning of the crisis that has
been done by the same team of
researchers who have um carried out
the research into into the statement
that we made yesterday so i i cannot
speak uh for uh for oxana i think that
um you know she would have to explain
her position herself i i don't have
anything to to comment on that if there
are these kinds of of internal divisions
though can your your crew and your
organization be trusted to to
objectively defend
the civilians best interests and human
rights in ukraine
i think again the
enormous body of work that amnesty
international has published to date on
war crimes
committed by russian forces all over
ukraine
you know
that is available on the public record
and anybody can see
um so you know the methodology is the
same the staff that have carried out the
work is the same uh i understand that
this particular piece of work because
it's critical of the behavior of uh of
ukrainian forces is not appreciated by
the ukrainian authorities and by many
others but the fact is that you know
international law um applies to everyone
and we as amnesty international have a
duty to investigate and report on uh
human rights abuses um violation of
international law regardless of who are
the perpetrators or the victims i mean
in this case of course the victims are
also ukrainians so
we're
thank you
we're joined now by andreas schuller
he's the director of the international
crimes and accountability program at the
european center for constitutional and
human rights mr schiller good to see you
what do you make of the amnesty
international report
well the report shows who pays the
biggest price in in a war and in every
war so that's the civilians they they
pay
extremely huge price especially if they
are
caught between the two fighting parties
and forces basically nevertheless there
are obligations under international law
for armies um to spare the civilians to
protect them
and and and they need to be obliged also
by by all parties it remains obvious
that russia is the aggressor here
aggressor here and that's that
the number of very well documented war
crimes by russia but again also all
parties to the conflict have certain
legal responsibilities to spare the
civilian population
nonetheless ukraine's president
responded with harsh criticism saying
that the report precisely equated the
victim with the aggressor what is your
take on that
i think it shows that that uh impartial
independent investigations are needed
and
um if possible also called judgments in
fair and international um um style
procedures
to um basically uh come to conclusions
here i mean there's not an allegation of
war crimes but of um
um neglecting the um the rules of war
and and the humanitarian law
um and and that's that series that can
be corrected of course um but it's also
clear that it's used in such a war by
both sides um um
from a more propagandistic view um and
that shows that independent
investigations are extremely necessary
to shed some light into these situations
what could be the legal consequences for
ukraine and its forces if these
accusations prove to be true
um
i mean we're not talking about war
crimes here so it's not criminal law
it's not prosecutions um there could be
some forms of reparations for the
victims who suffered in this situation
be at stake
but overall you also have to see that
armies worldwide
[Music]
unfortunately breach the law and and use
civilian installations to also have
military installations there providing
the other side basically a basis to
shell this area
um potentially legally if it's not
unproportionate um so it's it's
something in the in the fog of war that
happens in each and every war and and um
the legal consequences are more on the
reparation side but not so much on the
on the war crimes or prosecution side
here
you recently wrote that the conflict in
ukraine could transform international
criminal justice
and how so
um as there's such a focus on
international criminal justice there are
chances and and risks so the chances are
that the body of law that practice
prudence develops out of the conflict
through so many cases but the risks are
also that instruments that states and
others instrumentalize international
criminal law um so in in a very bad and
worrying direction and
as i think impartial independent
investigations uh and court cases and
legal cases are important um to draw the
right balance here um because it's not
black and white you have a clear
aggression here you have clear war
crimes here um but you need also proper
investigations to prove that
andreas of the european center for
constitutional and human rights thanks
so much for your time
russia's president says he's looking to
boost trade and economic ties with
turkey vladimir putin was speaking at a
meeting with turkey's president in the
black sea resort of sochi recep tayyip
erdogan said he hoped the talks would
open a quote different page in ties with
moscow
the leaders are also set to discuss the
grain deal brokered in part by turkey
which allowed the safe passage of
ukrainian grain
it's their second meeting since putin
invaded ukraine
so a lot to unpack there let's bring in
our correspondent dorian jones in
istanbul and dw's russia analyst
constantine again joining me from
vilnius good to see you both uh dorian
i'd like to start with you what does
turkish president erdogan have to gain
from this meeting
well i think he has a packed agenda but
he is speaking ahead of his meeting with
vladimir putin he said that the ukraine
grain deal will be a key item on their
talks uh for turkey which brokered this
deal with the u.n it is seen as a major
diplomatic triumph and erdogan will be
uh pressuring erdogan uh putin to
continue with this uh this ongoing
process uh as for erdogan because he
sees this is not only in diplomatic
success but also in a vindication of his
close ties with putin and he has faced a
lot of criticism from his western allies
uh but he's always insisted that
maintaining relation to putin is
essential for progress to be made also
erdogan will be raising the question of
syria he wants to launch a major
military operation against syrian kurds
which he says are linked to an
insurgency inside turkey now this
operation is targeting an area where
russia is in control and he needs the
support of russia together go ahead with
operation but putin has been very
reluctant over this he's very aware of
turkey's growing military presence in
syria and is also wearing the target
that turkey is proposing these key
towers of terror
which is causing a great deal of concern
not only for russia but also uh russia's
ally in syria iran and the assad regime
who both strongly opposed any operation
but erdogan and putin are really adept
at managing differences and in many ways
often coming up with very creative
solutions it all depends what erdogan
has to offer in exchange for our russian
greek life
so let's first dig in a little bit
deeper onto that diplomatic triumph as
you call it for the grain deal that was
partially brokered by uh turkey
constantine
given that praise do you think that
erdogan could also play a role in moving
putin closer to some kind of peace
agreement in ukraine
let's see it's a more
kind of pertinent question today than it
was even five days ago because after
charleston sherida former chancellor
schroeder of germany uh gave an
interview uh in which he said that putin
is open to negotiations actually after
actually meeting with putin we may think
i mean there is a ground let's say to
think that moscow really wants to have
some kind of talks and in this respect
erdogan is of course the best candidate
to be a mediator since russia's
falling out with israel erdogan is
pretty much the only global leader and
definitely the only nato country leader
who is still on speaking terms with
vladimir putin so yes why not maybe they
will discuss something tentatively
although i think that even if they do it
won't be put on the table straight away
after this meeting that usually takes a
bit more time
and dorian i want to get a bit more
about the interesting role that turkey
plays here it's been walking a political
tightrope when it comes to the war in
ukraine and on the one hand it's not
supporting international sanctions
against russia but on the other it's
delivering drones to ukraine how do
those two pieces fit together
well turkey is from the very onset of
this conflict was always argued has been
in a very difficult situation given that
ukraine and russia are neighbors across
the black sea uh and even before the
conflict started turkish president
rejected iran had very close relations
with both ukrainian and the russian
presidents and in many ways as this
conflict unfolded turkey has played what
they describe as this balanced approach
yes on the one side they've been
providing ukraine with very
sophisticated uh drones which have been
very uh successful in and inflicting a
lot of damage on russian hardware but at
the same time they haven't they haven't
uh imposed russian sanctions uh that are
from its western allies in spite of a
lot of criticism coming from many of its
allies and irma has always insisted we
have to play this balanced approach we
have to keep on talking to russia in
fact ahead of the the flights assaulting
he reiterated we either want a peaceful
solution to the ukraine conflict you've
got to talk to russia and erdogan
believes he's positioned himself as
really the only the western leader that
can talk with both the ukrainian leaders
the russian leaders as well as being the
nato partner as well so turkey believes
that even if it isn't yet both sides
either ukraine or or russia are ready
for peace talks yet if they are when
they are turkey isn't an ideal position
and i think that they will be looking
going forward at least for early steps
and uh building on the grain deal
success possible prisoner exchanges
between russia and ukraine and that is
something also erdogan is expected to
bring up and to build momentum from the
initial success of this granger
okay our correspondent dorian jones in
istanbul and russia analyst constantine
eggert thank you both so much for that
update
you